let's think about what happens to an is
curve when government spending
government spending goes up and to think
about that let's just let's let's first
draw our Keynesian cross so on the
vertical axis over here we have
aggregate expenditures in the horizontal
axis right over here we have aggregate
income these are really just two ways of
talking about GDP and so we are thinking
we actually want all the points where
the economy's in equilibrium where
income is equal to expenditures and so
that's why we draw that line of slope
one that's all of the points where
income is equal to expenditures where
our economy is in some type of
equilibrium or in equilibrium and then
we think about planned expenditures and
planned expenditures we've done this
multiple times it's equal to aggregate
consumer spending which is a function of
income minus taxes or it's a function of
disposable income and we're not saying C
times y minus T we're taking saying C is
a function of Y minus T this is one way
of talking about our consumption
function we assume it's linear in this
video and in others but it doesn't have
to be it could be a curve of some kind
and then we have our planned investment
plus planned investment which we're
assuming we're assuming that we're
sitting at some that our real interest
rates are fixed right now so planned
investment plus government spending plus
government spending and then we can even
throw net exports out there if we assume
that we have some type of an open
economy and this curve our planned
investment this is all a review of the
Keynesian cross videos it might look
something like this it might look
something like this and we get to our
equilibrium we get to our equilibrium
level of GDP and so we can also use this
information given that we were sitting
here at interest rate r1 to start to at
least plot one point to plot one point
on our is curve so let's draw at least
one point on our is curve and we
hopefully you feel good about the
general shape of it and then we could
think about how the is curve might shift
so here we have real interest rates
we're trying to rate relate real
interest rates to aggregate GDP so we
just showed that when we're real
interest
are sitting at r1 so if this is if this
is r1 right over here if real interest
rates are sitting at r1 we know that the
aggregate level of output or income is
that point right over there so we could
just drop that down and so it is this
level right over here so when real
interest rates are r1 this is our output
that is a point on our is curve and so
we can draw the entire is curve which
might look something like might look
something like that
that is our entire is curve if we kept
changing this we kept trying this out
for different for different real
interest rates we could plot more and
more of these points along the is curve
and so and it's and this is really
thinking in terms of how does real it if
real interest rates go up then this
whole expression will go down then this
thing will be shifted down and so we
would have less GDP your equilibrium if
this gets shifted down your equilibrium
GDP might go over here so at a higher
real interest rate you would have lower
lower aggregate income and so that's how
we actually thought about plotting our
highest curve now with all of that out
of the way let's think about what
happens when government spending goes up
well government if government spending
goes up if this piece right over here
goes up that will shift that will shift
our planned expenditures up as well and
so your change in government spending so
change in gee it would shift this curve
up it would let me draw that a little
bit neater it would shift this curve up
and you would get to a new level of
income or equilibrium level of real GDP
and that amount we actually this Delta Y
which is this amount right over here
it's actually going to be equal to the
multiplier which is 1 or 1 minus the
marginal propensity to consume times our
change times our change in government
spending but you'll have to worry about
this too much for the sake of this video
that's just a little bit of review but
the whole reason when I'm doing this is
we're saying look we're assuming r1
didn't change and when we increased
government spending when we increase
government spending it's shifted GDP up
by that amount so when you increase
government spending it shifted at r1 it
shifted it by that amount it shifted it
by that
well that would be true at any of the
real interest rates along the is curve
and so in general if you increase
government spending and you're not
changing any of this other stuff then
the is curve would shift to the right
and if you decreased government spending
the is curve would shift to the left so
with that in our toolkit now we can
think about how a change in government
spending might change our equilibrium
point in our is LM model and so let's do
that so once again real interest rates
here we have we have aggregate income or
real GDP and then we have our is curve
or is curve looks something like that
and our LM curve I will do an I will do
it in magenta our LM curve might look
something like that and so if we have an
increase in government spending we
already saw the is curve shifts to the
right shift to the right I don't want to
do that in the same color so it shifts
to the right and it will might look
something like that and so if our old
our old equilibrium real interest rate
was sitting here and equilibrium income
was sitting here we saw that by
increasing the government spending our
new our new equilibrium GDP is higher
and our new equilibrium interest rate is
higher just by the shift to the is curve
now you might be saying okay Sal you've
been focusing on the is curve but does
an increase in government spending does
it affect the LM curve doesn't a change
in fiscal policy does that affect the LM
curve we're not talking about printing
more money we're talking about the
government spending more increasing its
budget well remember the LM curve it's
driven by people's liquidity preferences
at different levels of GDP how much do
they want to hold money and how much are
they how much would you have to pay for
them in terms of interest for you them
to depart with it or how much interest
are they willing to pay to get access to
money at different levels of GDP so
that's not really infected by government
spending and it's also impacted by the
money supply by the amount of money that
are out there and just general levels of
prices and you could start to think
about all well doesn't government
spending affect prices and longer but if
we just hold a lot of those things
constant especially in the short term if
you especially if you hold prices
constant fiscal policy is not going to
change
the LM curve monetary policy the money
supply part that could or people's
liquidity preferences could but just
government policy by itself
fiscal policy by itself won't change it
so if we in this model just you know not
trying to get too over complicated when
government spending goes up when G goes
up it would shift the is curve to the
right
increase in real interest rates increase
increase in real GDP according to this
model